and to present the Academy Award for
sound effects editing the best bus
driver since Ralph Kramden honey and
she's a doll miss Sandra Bullock
speed probably would have come to a dead
stop without them and while you're
sleeping probably would have been a bit
of a snore sound effects help bring a
movie to life in this year three motion
pictures have been nominated for
excellence and sound effects editing
John Levesque Bruce Stambler for Batman
Forever long bender hair Hallberg for
Braveheart George waters a second for
Crimson Tide
and the Oscar goes to lawn bender and
pair Hallberg for a part
thank you I believe the greatest gift
you can ever give or get in life is to
live work and grow up among people that
believe in you then you can do basically
anything so I just wanted to thank my
family in Sweden and all my friends and
icon Productions Paramount Studios
Karen Baker and the great crew at Sound
Alexa put this all together for us thank
you I'd like to thank my friends and
family and especially my partner Wylie
stateman
and the staff at San delux whose
commitment to excellence has made this
possible this award is emblematic of the
struggle of people everywhere to achieve
something special in their working lives
and it's an honor to that devotion and
I'd like to thank everyone involved with
this picture
even cigar
I know what y'all thinking what's the
Gaul doing up here presenting an Oscar
for sound well there's a reason a couple
years ago under siege was nominated for
best sound and it lost I was devastated
I was crushed I was hurt I was beside
myself but somehow I I kind of got over
it and win or lose when you're nominated
for an Oscar
it's a big deal and the Academy knows
how to lift your spirits if you don't
win sometimes you still get to present
the nominees for best achievement in
sound are Rick d or Steve Peterson Scott
millon and David McMillan for Apollo 13
Donald ole Mitchell
Frankie McDaniel Michael Hrbek in Peter
CLE del for Batman Forever Andy Nelson
Scott Millen and of Bill Maher and Bryan
Simmons for Braveheart Kevin O'Connell
Rick Klein Gregory H Watkins and William
B Kaplan for Crimson Tide
Steve Maslow Greg land occur in Keith a
Western for Waterworld the Oscar is
awarded to Rick D or Steve Peterson
Scott Miller and David Maclaurin for
Apollo 13
Thank You Academy I like to thank
Universal Pictures I like to thank the
producers Brian Grazer Todd Halliwell I
like to thank most of all Ron Howard for
making such a spectacular movie about
the NASA space program Jim Lovell since
systems of New York and LA consider
contributions I like to thank film
editors dan Handley and Mike Hill I like
to thank dialogue editors chick
chicolini Lisa Levine I like to also
thank my backroom crew Bobby ship Alice
Bobby Oh Larry and my son Scott Dr and
in Los Angeles we want to thank Stephen
flick and his staff of effects editors
including Donald flick Dean Beville and
Ezra Dweck thanks to Tadeo Studios for
putting us all together and we want to
thank our families for putting up with
the long hours and the weeks away from
home and we just want to say to Ron
Howard that a special part of this
belongs to you Ron thanks